it's time to babble the [ __ ] on this
Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman is Monday morning in Hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman oh my god
welcome to the some wood it is ralph
it's the social distancing edition of
Hollywood babble-on I am sitting so far
away from Ralph's decent 4 foot yeah
they say six you're supposed to do six
[ __ ] them we always bend the rules in
our favor and we got always trying to
find a little bit for ourselves
I'm from Jersey's [ __ ] Philly we're
always looking for a little taste it's
the wet our beaks a little bit that's
all if they fell off the truck that's
cool everything we just need a little
just an edge just to get ahead a little
bit so we are social socially distance
from one another but more importantly
ladies and gentlemen we are socially
distanced from you you ain't gonna get
the coronavirus from us no best piece of
advice before we jump into all the
shenanigans if you're listening to this
right now go wash your hands yes wash
we'll wait
yeah and in silence we'll sing happy
birthday twice to ourselves why right we
were supposed to be doing shows at the
end of the month I've been on the road
with Jay and Silent Bob reboot Roadshow
tour thank the [ __ ] good Lord above
thanks mod if you will that that is over
before all of a sudden we've been
shuttered into our house that would have
been a problem
oh I mean look I'm not like underplaying
how horrible pandemic is but you know
all these businesses getting hit and
[ __ ] like that mine would have been hit
just as hard if I still had to go out
and tour so mercifully that tour is over
and thank Christ people came out for it
man and every night of that tour I saw
you and I saw people [ __ ] like react
to you respond to rounds of applause
every time you hit the screen it was
[ __ ] beautiful
particularly strongest every place we've
ever been so I could always gauge like
you know I brought we do road shows a
lot I do road shows
Babylon it to him the J and stuff I've
done stand-up by myself and whatnot
but every time you know we were in sixty
five cities every time 67 if you count
the Europeans I'd like cuz I went to
London three every time I could gauge
whether Babylon had been there or not by
how deafening the applause there was
always applause because there's always
Babylon people in the audience there's
always like the podcast people in the
audience that's primarily how we sold
our tickets right so naturally there's
always like I it's [ __ ] him but the
cities where we've ever mean [ __ ]
Philly [ __ ] dude you could have run for
mayor
based on your applause level alone and
[ __ ] like that so it was it was a
wonderful reminder throughout the entire
tour of like oh I've got this other life
waiting for me back at home and what I'm
working on right now is since we've got
time and we're trapped in the house and
staffing but I'm going back through all
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot footage
and just putting together like the route
cut cut scenes so what I'm building
right now is if you saw Jay and Silent
Bob reboot you saw Ralph played the
great Ted under his head under Hill
which of course a big flood shadow um
you know he was like fine I'll read you
my out reads my credit ground number out
loud to show you Bob what and then he
starts reading he reached three numbers
and then we cut to Fred Armisen pulling
up and stuff we shot like a whole other
bit where Ralph finishes and I'm gonna
build it Ralph finishes the number and
then we kept adding stuff where I never
got into the security questions a great
number of security questions about
having me over the phone my mother's
name I could prove my identity we and it
was always a series of J going like yeah
but we don't have security I'm gonna put
that together and here's my question to
you yes do you want it for
Ralph's report patreon or do you want it
ooh what you go on that my world isn't
an exclusive for you too
say hey that will be a nice dangle you
know what I'm saying come in and watch
this that would be a great special offer
if you signed up now you get to see the
remainder of Ralph's footage from Jay
and Silent Bob reboot that would be a
tremendous help so that's what's going
to encourage people to sign up for the
Ralph number one if you're sitting here
listening to [ __ ] babble on why
aren't you or Ralph's report listener
number two now you've got incentive man
[ __ ] Ralph in about two weeks or
whatever maybe less gonna have seen
those Kevin Smith's junkie where do you
taste
where do you put your exclusive content
patreon is a great service you can put
up any kind of content that you create
you can do visuals you can do video you
can do audio you can do text and the
only way to access is if you're is if
you are a general in the garmi yeah
that's and I can choose who gets what
and I can break it down into
subscription levels and things like that
so it's a real good service so I'll
include I would also include like all
the [ __ ] include everything I'll
build the scene and then I'll do the
outtakes and [ __ ] that would be a
blessing sir let's do it once again I
will ride the back of Kevin Smith to the
promised land
Ralph's reboots in a very special Oh
Ralph report
Ralph report patreon exclusive magic all
right I'm done good night everybody
I so the road was wonderful to me yes
I've seen you in months
oh it was great I said it every night
I've said it many places but it was like
going to a church every single night
where I was both the priest and Jesus at
the same time I'm just being celebrated
and celebrant and oh it was lovely and
the audiences were so [ __ ] great it
made me go like this is how I want to
like this is how I wanted to film like
you know I saw some cats were like you
know if like there was an article that
Forbes put out the other day that was
solid that you're breaking records in
single screen engagements they an it and
it was it was nice but like there are a
bunch of people that were like this
movie was out and it was like yeah but
not the way that normal movies are out
like we didn't want spend [ __ ] 10 to
20 million dollars in marketing to hope
that you show up the theater we went
this other way where I'm like
all right we're gonna book 65 city tour
I'll be there with every screening of
the moving stuff so instead of like
coming to see like Jay and Silent Bob
get old live it's like they came to see
Jane saw Bob reboot Roadshow tour so
they got an intro movie and then like an
hour Q&A afterwards and stuff so I loved
that model and right now that model is
mine and I see articles where people
write like at the end of that article
they were like this is like smart and a
possible way forward for you know
[ __ ] theatrical distribution for
exhibition because it's that window is
closing to a lot of movies unless you're
a Marvel movie yeah sure like you know
[ __ ] Harry Potter or Star Wars like
event movies or what draw people to the
theaters and right it's tougher and
tougher to I mean for an indie film to
find some space and a bad thing because
like now you know we go to any number of
streamers and there's places for the
work to be seen but as movie makers we
all dream about watching our movie in a
movie theater I found this little way
where I can do that where it's like I
don't have to [ __ ] gamble never mind
whatever you pay to make the movie this
ridiculous marketing costs on top of it
to be like I hope [ __ ] show up lose
limbs and all the money we made was
[ __ ] profits we didn't have to
advertise or anything that's kind of
specific to you too because you have a
relationship with your audience that not
a lot of filmmakers share you know some
people may know a filmmakers work but
they don't know the filmmaker precise so
the maker is a person that personal
relationship that helped definitely him
for years I've been sitting there with
the audience hanging out with them doing
shows interacting but I feel like there
are a lot of people Edgar Wright could
pull this off anybody here who's got
like an audience like a cult audience or
not just a cult audience but like a
[ __ ] file I mean let's be honest if
Chris Nolan was like I'm gonna take you
know 10 it out on 65 City tour and we're
gonna play it in [ __ ] like we played
big theaters like 1500 I think that big
theater that was 2000 seater
Wow he could take a movie like that and
do you know [ __ ] Radio City Music
Hall [ __ ] massive square garden or
something like that
right but you know Warner Brothers like
we're in the business of [ __ ] making
crazy money Organic wasn't a carpet bomb
this film we're not we're not looking
for a strategic we like we live in the
future not in the past cuz what I'm
doing is not like this is ingenious this
is what they used to do used to be
called for walling back in the day or
even with like the big-ass [ __ ]
movies like Gone with the Wind gone with
the wind wasn't like you know a man I
lived in Washington I'm giving you a
phone call in New York do you just go
see gone with the wind the two o'clock
matinee that [ __ ] did not exist it's
like hi I'm in New York I watch gone
with the wind it's here for a few months
man because this is it the only print
and this is where it goes next it's
going to Chicago and [ __ ] like that
right so it's not even like this is
ingenious I'm just like I want backwards
I often thought about on the road how
like I'm reversed Tyler Perry at this
point Tyler Perry he went out and he
built like his audience with live shows
right he's do little plays for people
all the time and and packed houses and
had a circuit and then one day he was
like you know [ __ ] I could there's a lot
more effective you know reaching way
more people with movies and so the Madea
movies happen and then he's built like
he's got a [ __ ] studio out in Georgia
zone like goddamn studio and stuff I'm
the guy who's like I think Tyler Perry's
life looked more interesting to me when
when he was building like I just went
backwards I started with like you know
working for like a studio to some degree
and now I'm content to like work the
circuit are you saying we're gonna do
clerks three is a play I just it's
traveling your clothes Marrakesh so
close I've fought for this tour though
by the end of the tour midway through
the tour I was like I know exactly what
onto the clerks three number one I want
to pay for it
I want anybody else's money I'm gonna
[ __ ] like I'll refinance this house
and stuff you want to talk about keeping
a responsible budget when every Penny's
coming out of your pocket
I'll be like what did that paper cost I
got that bring paper from home you don't
need to buy bagels down yeah that's you
know you need all of it that's an end of
the day bagel
I want to finance it myself and then I
want to go on on tour and tour it for a
year cuz we did four months and I was
like oh [ __ ] I coulda kept going I mean
thankfully right now I wasn't on tour
because that and that's the thing you
can't foresee something like pandemic
right
but barring a pandemic I could live on
the [ __ ] road for a year with the
movie and go everywhere and I could
build a smarter schedule where it's like
we'd go three weeks on one week off so
you know I'm always going home at a
certain point or at least having like a
little time off and stuff I could do
that for a year no [ __ ] like let's
say we made clerks three for like four
million that's my new [ __ ] dream
believe me I'm like can we make it for a
million but you know I realize the costs
or whatever the costs are and stuff
because we're grown-ups now yeah you
know I can't make a movie in New Jersey
which is the New York Council of unions
and stuff and and do it on the cheap you
got it everyone's gotta get paid for
that way and stuff so let's say you know
in a world where Jay and Silent Bob
reboot it was a ten million dollar movie
but after 20 percent rebate you know
shooting in Louisiana is an eight
million dollar movie we got ourselves if
we keep this clerk's it's all one place
all it takes place a quick stop so
you're not moving around whereas reboot
we were moving around every damn day
you're in one locked
keep that to 4,000,000 and now I'm
sitting here going maybe even three but
let's just say four just to be careful I
could tour that for a year and make 10
million dollars and that would mean a
nice six million dollar profit yes I
don't know any other world in which I
will ever earn six million dollars in
one year let alone ten ever again you
know what I'm saying yes so for me
that's like you know because the
sacrifice is you're on the road like
you're just what we did we're doing it
three times right but the reward is
financially [ __ ] lucrative and that's
real money that's not like now we got to
pay these people back and 50% has to go
the exhibitors and stuff that's that's
real like that's that's I mean I that's
I hate to borrow I love to borrow from
uncut gems that's how I win you know and
I'm sampling that's I'm never nobody
ever gonna pay me six million god do
anything in this lifetime right but if I
[ __ ] lump it and like I'm four wall
in it I'm carrying my [ __ ] left my
heart out to the fanbase which by the
way is no schlep it's no work every
night
like a [ __ ] god and I can't think of
a better way to live can't think of a
better way to spend like my 50s you know
what I'm saying like so if I make a
movie that's how I'm taking it out like
you know I don't believe me Jordan find
me already like you're not living on the
road for a year I said watch me but you
know it'll probably be some tailored
version of that dream but it's possible
like I know now what's possible and then
we've perfected this touring thing for
ourselves not for the world but like
started with red state and [ __ ] and then
the next time we did it was with the
groovy movie country movie and this time
it was even more streamlined and then we
got it down to like it was an expensive
his [ __ ] bro the travel part of it was
nothing it was me Josh and lit dr. Josh
Roush our man in the in the [ __ ]
booth yeah at Babylon and his wife live
and then Jay was with me for the first
half of the tour and then afterwards it
was just me and Josh and live in an SUV
driving [ __ ] around like you can't get
more punk rock man I'm 49 and we were
just driving around out you know I was
wearing this [ __ ] hat and [ __ ] it
was beautiful like I felt way younger
than I should have and then every night
we went and put on a show you know we
just didn't have instruments we had the
movie instead right it's bliss so I
could live like that for the rest of my
life and you know I understand like
making movies the old-fashioned way and
carpet bombing the marketplace and like
yes that's to dream for others I I found
my place and I really [ __ ] liked it
and you know some people are like he's
not in business anymore and I'm like I
don't I don't know that I was ever
ambitious to be honest with you like
that was somebody else's [ __ ] money
playing a game that way I fell into a
studio system and I ain't bitching about
it was wonderful to see how it all
operate some stuff but I was more
prepared for this life like when I was
making clerks I thought I was gonna form
all that [ __ ]
so tip take clerks three outer modes
they pay for it all myself like I did
the first time and even the first time
was on credit cards this time literally
would be me like my liquidity or
whatever if I [ __ ] put the house up
that's my money that I'm putting into it
right if not somebody else's like
borrowed money or whatever [ __ ] and then
taking that movie out the way I intended
to take out clerks in the first place
that is punk rock is [ __ ] bro and that
to me is
more important than anything else in
this world is like doing things with the
work that like you know maybe not
everyone ever wants to do but nobody
else done first
like I like taking weird first steps and
like forging my own Road and some people
like that looks stupid but I'm like yeah
maybe you could be right in the moment I
bet you does look stupid but like let's
step back in ten years and see what the
paths look like you also have to play it
where it lays in life sometimes I gotta
say alright what are my options I can
bust my ass to try to get universal to
pay me X number of dollars to direct a
jurassic film or I got this opportunity
now that's for real that I know and I
like I mean that just this makes sense
in life let alone business and let's be
honest man like I ain't equipped to tell
you a Jurassic story but I could tell
you the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] Kevin
Smith movie you know and it's like they
got plenty of townspeople Colin
Trevorrow to go make those like [ __ ]
dinosaur movies and I've never once in
my life been like I want to make one of
those movies you know what drama the
ends of this was slacker you know
sitting there talking to each other so I
had a [ __ ] blast that all being so
they just put that a hiatus that a rat
Jurassic movie because the crooner
buggers but what they just put it on
high heat it's the production they
stopped production on drastically so
it's gonna start happening a lot more it
already has yeah I mean well the first
one we stopped and clerks three man
that's only six people in a room that's
true not breaking any rules as long as
we're socially distance from one another
six feet apart you know if Dante and
Randall can't stand right next to each
other at the counter there's gonna be a
lot of single here single there but you
get the same ice wish pans to be honest
with you it's a very simple shot to
green-screen so true you shoot Brian
first shoot Geoff second marry them
together and there's such good
performers you'll think they were in the
same [ __ ] frame magic the we might as
well jump into the [ __ ] news of it
all yeah I have about me unless do you
want to catch up on what you've been
doing where you been no I mean I've been
waiting for you to come home
you're funny because people were
listening to this are the same people
have been saying Hollywood babble-on
coming back that's like well if you know
the man you know he's out on the road we
can't do it when we're not in the same
city so thanks to everybody for being
patient and waiting for the boys are
back I wanted
as much as they did of course we but we
all did that's why I felt like saying
you know we're not we're not holding it
back from you it's not we're not
begrudging you a show we're dying to do
it we just got to wait for the man to
return so I'm just happy you're off the
road I'm so delighted to for that
respect to be done I was sad to see the
tauren but I'm like it's not like I'm
not gonna see an audience again just the
next time I see the audience I will have
to change my my pattern yeah like that
was the other [ __ ] thing you go on
tour like you know you got 19 things
that you say that work everywhere yep
and you fall into like you know here's
my mantra was [ __ ] locked in stone and
like changed based on where we were
minimally but like insert city here oh
it was bliss and you know I as much as I
love it and it's a nice vacation
Babylon keeps [ __ ] sharp you
know what I'm saying because there's new
every week and yeah and you can't and
how Babylon is like like I don't you
know I'll be able to reach into a back
pocket and pull out an old kept story if
it's appropriate here or there but it's
sink or swim like it's it's either I'm
staring at Ralph's going like wow he's
good or I got a [ __ ] tread water and
swim and try to be as funny and often
more yes yes you have magical moments
during that show I loved watching you do
that for that reason which is watching
your mind turn and then have you come up
with something that just crushes it is
as much a pleasure for me as it is for
the audience because we get to be each
other's audience too because it's all
improvised will do and after almost 10
years of this we've sort of gotten each
other's rhythms down and we can set each
other up and stuff is just so much fun
it's still one of my favorite moments of
well last year and this year because it
was on the same night we were on the
[ __ ] show and that was like oh
have you seen Watchmen I haven't seen
anything I've been getting divorced and
my dad is dying I got time for baby Yoda
no you go I got time a jerk-off a biota
Oh half second half of the tour periodic
I'd be chuckle on the car and I'd be
like to Josh and Liv exploded
been given a super-sized menu order of
real life that's for sure as a man you
got to put that on your gravestone ain't
got time to be jerking off baby yeah
that's for sure
so and Here I am by the way social
distancing with a guy who has seen more
people and been in contact with more
people in the past three months than
anyone in the United States what am I
thinking
hi guys you coughing I think that's it
I'm walking out of here with a fever I
was in Trader Joe's for a minute
yesterday cuz I was I'm not one of these
people let's go [ __ ] emergency
shopping until I read an article where
it said weed stores overrun and
yesterday morning I was like oh [ __ ] and
I called up the weeds to her and there I
was like is it end of the world crowded
there and the guy goes nah man is cool
come on in my people my people so I for
the second that I started ever getting
about you know when they use the word
pandemic and stuff I'm not big
germaphobe and stuff but I'm can read
the tea leaves it's like something bad
is happening like it and it's only gonna
get worse but my I think it was Jennifer
that calmed me down for either Jorden
one of the two said you just got home
from a 65 city tour across three
countries and you didn't even get a cold
like I think your immune systems
allegory shape but as we all know that's
not the thing it's not being carried on
and I live in a house with elderly
people Jen's parents live with us so now
we can't we are literally socially
distancing ourselves from them or like
hi guys can't run the risk of being
somebody as you said who's been out
there in the world and should be typhoid
Kevin yeah but you got one of them
[ __ ] you got a kid those are [ __ ]
ground zero for its I prefer germs and
[ __ ] they don't get it apparently now
there's massive like rats they're like
the rats during the plague and then I
grow you just scurry around and just
give it to everybody else more ways than
one
Ralph they're like rats during the
[ __ ] plague did your kids school get
canceled yeah she's home now and for how
long until after spring breaks
she won't be back into school depending
on what happens with everything until
mid-april
what happened what happens then do they
make them go to school until July know
what they're doing at least with her
school is they're trying a new technique
of homeschooling via for the virtual
world so she'll have virtual classes
from now until spring break when she
would get her normal time off and then
they'll really and see if they'll
continue that way or they'll get back
into the classroom after that good dream
and when I was in school the dream was
always like go to school but without
your pants on yeah I could literally do
that yes I thought well that was the
nightmare actually but now you could do
it in a dream way you could be literally
in class and your pants off and if
you're quiet and I'm what grade is this
she's in fourth alright so let's move
this up a little bit before I go further
let's say your college kid and you're
doing this virtual class thing you could
literally jerk off while class is going
on and people wouldn't know it that's
where you go that's where your mind goes
I mean
gotta find a edge to sign for silver
lining to this [ __ ] cloud hopper
teacher says no I'm saying you can keep
another window open where you're
learning I got you yeah we don't know
what's gonna happen this is another
experiment you know she's gonna have to
be responsible for her own assignments
and though they'll assign the work but
she's got to do it on her own it's like
independent study for a nine-year-old
how successful is that model going to be
we'll find out that like they could do
it they don't need the old model and
[ __ ] well they already said that the
social aspect of going to school is the
going to be the most detrimental for
these kids who aren't spending time in
the class you know prolonged time out of
school combined with prolonged they're
really begging green time a lot more
data more screen time and they're also
begging kids not to get together in
large social groups or no playdates none
of this it's very isolating and they say
that can have a real bad effect on kids
so that the kids are gonna see it like
woohoo because they're already [ __ ]
faces and screens this whole generation
yeah I don't know now they're like no
you're gonna go school on the [ __ ]
screen too but my kid like she's on the
stop fourth grade soccer team she loves
her team and she loves her playdates and
they get together in groups and she
won't be able to do any of that so we'll
see it's a long time for an
year-old to sort of be just with mom and
dad and you can't even and now that
means she's home with you yeah so you
can't even be like let's go to
Disneyland now that [ __ ] gone to
Universal Studios closed Disneyland
closures closed sure most people saw the
fact to it online but they've closed
only three times prior to this and each
of those times only for one day apiece
yeah right now they're closed till like
April main base early
yeah mid April mid April so the only
three other times that closed Disneyland
assassination of Kennedy yep the
Northridge earthquake right which for
those who are like what the [ __ ] is that
there's a pretty big earthquake out here
I guess yeah and how did that affect
anything with Disney Land affect him
well no they were just careful because
it had been the biggest serious quake
and so that you can check all the tracks
make sure and then the third one was of
course September 11 yeah one day each
Disney World is just I believed
announced they're also shutting down is
the real [ __ ] Disney Paris shut the
the biggest though the when when this
got real for everybody was when the
first celebrity was him and they
couldn't have picked a worse celebrity
to go after the one who must be saved at
all cost it was it was like you were
writing a parody of a pandemic movie in
which Tom Hanks was the star yes or even
know he's like the surprise cameo you
know it's like you and I are goofing
around in the pandemic parody comedy and
really oh no the first celebrity got it
cut to Tom Hanks doing us a favor and
playing himself in that cameo where he's
in Australia in a isolation room not
holding the volleyball who got a mare
you you did I don't have any connection
Hanks this fantasy falls right the [ __ ]
apart for makers I'm like how unless
Ralph got him how did we get Hanks in
our movie well you know we got a Hanks
in our movie [ __ ] the virus we win well
that's how we win Ralph it turns out
Colin Hanks is a real good friend of
mine he's been on your kids go to school
together
oh so Colin and I are our school dad
buddies we do that stuff and so when it
happened I
reached out and I said I feel bad cuz I
know you're gonna get bombarded stuff
but I just want to reach out and tell
you you know we're thinking of you and
everything and he wrote back very funny
it's like thanks pal I appreciate he
goes by the way they got in Australia I
haven't seen my dad in a while I know I
gave your kid a ride home the other day
there's more concerned about our social
circle than his parents but yeah it was
nuts
and it really drove it home it's so
funny how of that's a STONER Croft
ladies and gentlemen s a famous face
will hang a level of sincerity and
seriousness on a disaster more than
anything else in this country a good
man's like when Rock Hudson got AIDS
remember and suddenly people like now
this is a disease this is a real disease
the when I walked into Trader Joe's for
a minute with the kid the other day
yesterday the lines were 25-person deep
I haven't even gone and to be fair
Trader Joe's was doing wonderful job
processing people but I walked in and
saw that I was like I'm waiting here I'm
gonna go outside and I coughed and
[ __ ] everybody looked and then I was
like stoner and they're like alright
alright cool man went back to normal and
[ __ ] yeah that's the thing man like
coffin is a real trigger for a lot of
people but brother if I don't coffin in
it's good that's true
coffin makes it better I'm buying into a
lot of it but I'm not buying into the
panic hoarding shopping phase yeah it's
not that kind of disaster in my opinion
this isn't an earthquake or fire
situation where all this shit's gonna go
away I can't imagine they're they're
gonna close the grocery stores last if
they have to close [ __ ] down don't mean
you can still get a burrito and so I'm
like toilet papers but you're worried
about like water like if they told me
like all the [ __ ] waters being bought
I'd be like I bet you man I bet you but
toilet paper it's like even water
there's a pipe I know have you seen it
by your sink it's got a handle did you
turn that that is it gonna sound crazy
but water just [ __ ] flows out of it
oh [ __ ] how much how much nothing
just turn it
was it costly just turn it on believe it
[ __ ] you Billy yet will Billy at the end
of the month I need my pulling Springs
at the end of the month um toilet paper
like maybe it's just maybe I'm like I
got so many books I got so many [ __ ]
like I got plenty [ __ ] to wipe my ass
with and I'm just like turn on the
shower [ __ ] grab a shower nozzle do
shush it out I gotta watch myself off I
wash myself up totally man maybe I'll
learn something new maybe I'll be like
hey that's the way it always should have
bet there's a cleaner whitepapers for
animals well I mean think about if you
step in dog [ __ ] you try to clean your
chute with paper how much is left behind
I'm not walking into the house that's
for sure I'm certainly not on your
[ __ ] and if you can and you're like
my dog Shecky my glands need to be
expressed I did that on the road no you
didn't like join me for the last 15
dates she looked up yeah I did and at
one point like she's eating a lot of
[ __ ] greasy fast food so I'm like I
should probably get her [ __ ] [ __ ]
Express cuz she was like doing a shuffle
on the car but yeah and I brought her in
in where were we
[ __ ] it was no [ __ ] somewhere on
these coasts man and maybe Georgia and
went into a vet's office and they were
like do you have an account with us and
I'm like I just do you need that to
squeeze this dog's anal glands like how
much about me do you need to know how
much about her do you need today history
medical history do you need to get a
tissue and squeeze this dog's ass - I
may tell you about the times you got in
a fight with Marty and Marty bitter ass
shed - when I asked for like a month
does that count King just squeezes talk
shut look show me how to do it and I'll
do it I just no no you don't want to do
it have you ever seen it done yes what
happens it's it's where is it what the
gland is ring around the [ __ ] yeah
and you know I mean how did you see it
you've seen it cuz I take when I take
Reggie who's a neurotic mess into the
vet Eisley I'm Bob I gotta stand by him
and hold him usually but [ __ ] look at
that look why why are you you're helping
- and the stuff that comes out of there
it looks like the black oil from x-files
oh really
it's not good on any level and how are
they doing it that is it literally
squeezed yeah they get a paper towel and
they squeeze the glam and wait paper
towel but not a glove yeah they glove up
but what they're using they take a paper
clap towel and they just squeeze the
gland and Express it's like popping a
zit basically how do you think the dog
feels about it
at the time I can't imagine they dig
imagine someone bends you over and
squeezes your [ __ ] with a paper towel
see how you feel but to be fair there
are more of like an [ __ ] centric
culture right like they're always
sniffing each other's bones that's why I
think they're [ __ ] plays an even
larger role in their daily lives and it
does with us and so when you get around
that area it'd be like somebody poking
their fingers in your mouth or something
they could they get panicky that's true
I guess if somebody walks up to me
squeezing your tongue but afterwards I
think they feel a great sense of relief
and then like oh that's better
sounds like it defines a dog's life like
panic and then a great sense of really
yeah that's true everything man even
when you hand him a new piece of food
and that's dog Babylon
[Laughter]
so the first production effected I think
was the Elvis movie that Tom Hanks is on
in Australia with with well the phrase
Norman the first boys in it - yes Elvis
yeah my friend from my yoga hosers yeah
Austin Pendleton no yes Austin is
playing Elvis yes and which one is
Austin Pendleton something dad from now
he's think now he's the guy with the
glasses who was always the nerd in all
like the 70s movies yeah yeah I can
that's I think he was in here see what's
up doc now that was max right where's
the dad from Ralph Oh Alf
did you ever see what's updog Peter
Bogdanovich with that yeah yeah he's
he's one of the leads in that
so you what you were gonna say different
movie was shut down um well all the live
shows that had audiences where the first
ones affected they stopped recording in
front of live audiences all the late
night shows they we always started like
two days ago
no even beforehand they were they were
taking on jeopardy wheel although chin
all those late nights stopped and just
on like notice but it started with a lot
of the syndicated shows that had
audiences they started to work without
audiences and then it crossed over into
film and television production where
they stopped my kid is on a show she was
supposed to the first week April go out
to Dallas to start her show but uh they
pushed a month for you know same thing
we were gonna open smart castle the week
of 4/20 clearly that's an that means an
easy push to because we wait a couple
more months then it's the ten year
anniversary of actual spot castles
opening that's crazy
and naturally Babylon will be there it
would make it a very far trip for a very
little audience and that would be a
pleasure for us plus it's a that means
we're on the cusp of the ten year
anniversary of Babel as well that's
right yardage Eggman shortly after you
open the year oh gee smart cow so we
started putting this up so were you on
you weren't on the prima nocta bill no
so that was July 10th so that means we
already started like August Wow yeah so
we got a big show coming up yeah where
do we book it I don't know here man
let's hear here your house yeah here's
the house we can have a hundred people
bring bring your suggestions for where
we should do the Hollywood babble-on
10th anniversary show pitcher pitch your
home pitch your home tell us where you
want us man and maybe we'll go there the
hashtag is Bab bold ten babble ten the
number or spell it out the number okay
you do that battle one zero I think
babble one zero okay and hey you know if
I include at me and Ralph of course
Ralph is what at Ralph Garman so
original and I'm that Kevin Smith just
one word more original yes add us and
then under the hashtag Babel ten tell us
where we should do the babel 10th
anniversary show great ice
the show there because it's coming I
mean we got a few months and we
certainly have [ __ ] time in our hands
to book a show hopefully by the time
August rolls around we'll be free to
travel about the world again oh my god
and if not god help us all really then
I'm Charlton Heston in Omega man oh I
thought you were telling this like damn
yo man I was driving you know I was
driving around Los Angeles to get to
your home and the streets are
unnaturally open wide you can get
anywhere now and I've reminded me of
Omega Man the Charlton Heston movie
where he is the guy who got the one dose
of vaccine against a pandemic that
turned everybody into zombies and he's
the only person who can exist during the
day and he's tooling around in his
Mustang just all by himself and it was
very reminiscent of one of those kind of
post-apocalyptic movies Omega gar man
that's right Kevin Smith I don't buy
your cough story I think you're infected
what was the guy's name the bad guy
Matthias yes listen Matthias I can help
you who is anthony zerbe ass he was
always like a bad always well remembered
thank you he's gone right yeah so strong
nest and they're all gone it's just us
so who won in the Mega Man war who went
first he sat in spoilers 1970s he was
made so you lose he sacrifices himself
at the end for the greater good
hoon is Chuck Heston there's a big sort
of like Jesus omage thing as he hangs
there on a wrought iron fence at the end
but in real life who passed first trial
Chuck did yeah Chuck win
so then ultimately the Matthias won
highest one the zombie's win just like
real life man they got do one more like
a PS they got to add a PS to all the
Omega men in real life one of these
actors but before the other to do with
the story they shut down the flash that
hurts why
now they're getting personal with me in
Canada yeah stop production on the flash
I wonder if everyone still gets paid I
was thinking that too I mean obviously
we want to do what's right for the for
the well-being of the species because
now this is a worldwide situation and
everybody is trying to stem the tide of
contagion pandemic does not care about
economics but you gotta think those
people who are day workers and you know
gig workers and the stuffs like I know
some of the sporting franchises have
announced they're still gonna some of
the NHL franchises of announce that
still be paying NBA as well even the
people who worked at the arena the
people who sold popcorn is [ __ ] and
everyone just what a that's a good great
gesture absolutely and completely doable
and they got more money than Croesus so
absolutely they should be doing an
opposite from the report out of what was
it Amazon where they were saying if
you've got some extra sick time give it
to your buddy yeah he can have sick time
right then what happens when it's time
for my sick time oh well there's another
robot maybe there'll be another buddy
yeah
that was kind of not a good look well
the guy's pinching pennies you have to
understand he doesn't have a lot of cash
she's gotta hurt right yeah should pay
for look we don't want to [ __ ] say
too much about Amazon no I literally get
everything priced particularly in the
middle of pandemics we don't want Jeff
Bezos going close that Prime accounts
making fun of me where they they will
get only regular shipping oh my god
working up the way two [ __ ] days [ __ ]
no it's true um what with her news Ralph
did you prepare any [ __ ] no we're
just the homeshow
to get to know your show so what's going
on and out there in the world then
business well this is going on it's the
only thing that is happened that's it
it's us I just always dreamed of we're
the only entertainment option I've got a
friend who works on a sports talk daily
podcast and he's like we don't know what
the [ __ ] we're gonna talk about oh my
god think about it
think about all the people they enormous
sports commenting industry ESPN all the
sports radio talkers their entire
format is just to talk about scores and
sports what do they have
there's no hockey there's no basketball
there's no baseball's going to be
delayed footballs offseason soccer
they're playing to empty stadiums if
they're playing at all I mean there's
nothing going on and it's it's becoming
that with entertainment I mean all the
the shows have canceled all of the tours
have canceled you can't see a live
musical act you can't go see a comedy
club we were gonna do this show at The
Improv in Oxnard at the end of the month
and the Improv said we're closing all of
our venues until April you can't do or
see anything I mean movie theaters now
AMC just said they're capping their
number of tickets that they can sell
above way below capacity so that people
can sit six feet away from each other
and watch a film what open this weekend
or what's opening this weekend a bunch
of really depressing films seem like a
bad weekend to have depressing films
there was that blood shot with Vin
Diesel yeah anytime Vin Diesel's in the
film that's depressing but there was the
abortion group the abortion Roy Cohn at
the box office
it was the abortion Roadshow never
hardly ever so Joe is the musical about
[ __ ] I want to live no as a Christian
movie no no that's uh I still believe
there's a movie about two teenage girls
in Pennsylvania who have to go to New
York City so one of them can get an
abortion oh I thought you were I thought
that was what the Christian movie no the
Christian movie is about true story
about the world's biggest Christian
music star whose wife gets cancer and he
wants the entire fan base to pray for
her and have Jesus save her life and
cure her is that true story it is a true
story and and she died [ __ ] spoilers
bro it's out there it's been established
because then he wrote after she died his
most famous single called I still
believe Oh so ah I see now so he it was
a test of faith it was and so even
though he asked everyone to pray for he
said Jesus I sing your songs I teach
your teachings I through the magic of
music to millions of people please save
my wife
her and she said and and he still
believes man that's um that's that's
fate yeah Wow
I mean yeah cuz death test your faith
yet does and in that instance that's I
mean hopefully there's something in
there about like you know that's that's
a that's presuming upon a friendship you
can you can pray for a lot of things in
this world but you can't like [ __ ] say
Jesus a save X Y or Z you can't do that
can 15 50 results right yeah don't say
don't say it folks out there at very
particular believes off I respect those
beliefs I'm just saying if you can't ask
for that mm-hm
it's not like you're saying oh can you
help me find my car keys Jesus you're
forgetting the plan Ralph I forget the
Divine Plan I forgot so yeah of course
some folks are called home my father was
called back because of course Jesus had
a job for him he wants him to cancel
stamps in heaven right so I got you I
just I just think that's it yes it's the
ultimate test of faith and then but
should you ask for it then does it prove
you're not faithful if you even ask for
it yes that's the double-edged sword you
saying God you are all-powerful you're
capable of all things please do this
thing or God just says nope know what
you're really saying is like you have a
plan this is all your doing nothing
happens without your say-so it's all by
divine design so well it's already in my
block you just to take your plan and
shove it up your ass because I have
[ __ ] plans that's what you're saying
like every prayer yes I'm not just
saying like the biggies like find my car
keys Lord like that's why you don't ask
Jesus for that you go to Saint Chris
Torres Saint Anthony he's the one who
finds your keys but Saint Anthony come
around something's lost and can't be
found yes come around that's when you
got ours with Cummings come down please
come down we see better our
invoking a [ __ ] spirit from above
yours like come around
that's very Philadelphia you've come
around could you come around my marquees
bring one witw is ours was like please
come down because you're [ __ ] dead
and when things are dead they must
descend to the dead earth again ma'am in
a minute yeah can't really make heavenly
[ __ ] metal no your striper really tried
but you can't really do it no back to
this [ __ ] thing yes you're asking
even with like lord please help me find
my car keys presumably the Lord lost
your keys for a reason part of the plan
and even though you're respond you know
and then you got a factor in well what's
my fault well what is your fault you
choose to sin you didn't choose to lose
your car keys
that was a Jesus thing nice being like
this will I look there's a reason and we
said that we should never pray really is
what you're saying I was doing I arrived
don't do it that's why it like when I
was dying I was not sitting there
praying I didn't want to pursue him upon
cuz the plans already in action also I
was like I thought the Lord would be
like you made dog Michael [ __ ] yourself
yeah die hard so one of those but again
I think we shouldn't offer thoughts and
prayers we should just off your thoughts
me moving forward same different like
offering those every time I see somebody
offering those thoughts of prayers it's
like I'll take thoughts thoughts are
great I'm keeping in my heart I like
that one yeah that sounds believable but
whenever you when I see celebrities say
like I'm praying for I hmm I don't know
you know look I'm being negative I just
I think I like to say I will never say
you're in my prayers cuz I would like I
don't pray now I'm not going to be like
Lord it's Kevin
hey it's been a while I didn't pray to
you when I was about to die there's this
woman Rebecca she's in Indiana she
hasn't asked and I really feel like you
know I saw and I'm not mocking those
that do that I'm not my personal ethos
is I would not presume upon a friendship
yeah
and the friendship that I have with the
Lord is I you know I get to be Kevin
Smith for until I die and and you know
every once in a while I'm like Lord did
it which I've pretty much stopped I
don't know I really fell off the rails
with all this welcome to speaking of
imposing babylon babylon ladies speaking
of imposing front friendship yes I had
them Greg Grunberg on my show a while
back on the ralph report yes and so we
were chatting and talking and we we had
a similar we had sort of a bonding
moment over the fact that he is lifelong
pals with Jay Jay yes and they worked
together a ton and we were talking about
my friendship with you and how kind you
are to always think of me and include me
in the many different projects that you
work on and I've hope I have expressed
my gratitude and my thanks for all they
all always all those opportunities that
you have given me always and he said are
you in he was asking about some project
I think it was reboot he said are you
are you gonna be in that I said yeah
Kevin said there's something in that for
me and I said I always been so grateful
and you know I never want to presume on
that friendship and say when I hear he's
working on something reach out and say
hey hey what do you got for me and Greg
said oh that's not me I always do that
he does if I read in the trades that JJ
just got to deal with that I call him up
and meet and go okay great well Who am I
playing yeah I'm like that's amazing to
me yeah I mean I'm good for him because
it is a superpower he gets a ton of
stuff because he does that but I would
be blown away if I was that guy I just I
wouldn't be I couldn't do it I think
yeah you blown away as the person
receiving the request
yes it's yeah I I know but otherwise and
he thought I was an idiot because I
don't call you up every time I see your
name in the trades and say what I'm Who
am I playing what am i doing what am i I
was like I yeah I always feel grateful
because like you know he had geeking out
was his thing yes it was he had a deal
that was already set up they'd sold the
show to emcee and AMC
like we would like you to be in that
show and I was like oh my god fantastic
so because of that we got to make six
episodes of TV show however many it was
my time got paid to do so and whatnot
met some other cool people who we got to
interview so when you know I was working
on flash and he's like Who am I playing
it just I was like oh my god I'll find
you something and like he did wasn't in
my episode but like I got him into the
flash Brantly hust him for a couple of
so again so there you know I felt like a
sort of like oh well [ __ ] the least I
could do and he likes this world and he
played snap Wexley and it makes sense
and sure but yeah everything pretty much
he'd hit me up about reboot but we were
almost done and you know I was we were
already staffed up it really is a
superpower I don't have that in me I
don't have that ability and I know other
people also like like him and [ __ ] a
stars born yeah I told them when I saw
that I was like oh my god like well done
sir because I know that was him going
like bradlee you're directing a movie
what's up and he knows Bradley from by
Elias Elias so yeah it is a superpower
that's uh god bless him because look
he's he's know a lot of action figures
snap oh absolutely and I was I was in a
costume in Star Wars and if you blank
him you missed me I'm happy to have done
it but like that was that he's on camera
talking he's in a scene with [ __ ]
Carrie Fisher yeah
because he's smart enough to like be
like Who am I playing that's he's he's
every time I did it struck me because
that phrase you used it's like that's
where my mind automatically goes that
I'm envious of his ability lack of guile
when it comes to that it's just kids the
lesson in all of this is go for yours
yep just worst that can happen is you
know [ __ ] you don't get something but
you ask and nobody gets she this is what
Greg learned early on in life nobody
gets anything unless you ask for it it's
so true and that's why my career is
where it is and that's where he's mine
as well and believe me I'm not unhappy
with my career I like my career but
sometimes I you know go like why isn't
like how come Netflix doesn't like ask
me to do that like I see somebody doing
like
you know who would have boys the
brothers the Duplass they've got like a
sweet little deal at Netflix where they
make multiple movies yeah do some dragon
why isn't like Netflix come to me and
asked me to do that cuz that's not how
it [ __ ] works maybe it works like
that for like you know squish Abrams or
they'll reach out to Scorsese be like
hey we'll make [ __ ] the Irishman right
over here we'll find you a home but like
generally speaking I got a knock on the
door somebody the de Plus brothers
probably went in and said no for sure
you got an idea this is what we like to
do you guys want pay for it can we be
here blah blah blah but it does begin
with the ask like it's it's weirdly
arrogant to assume that like well
they'll reach out if they want me I
guess the smart play forward is always
just like if you want to play in that
sandbox let it be known i sat down with
a new agent the other day them for the
first time like my agent my
representation has changed over the
years
like when I began in this career I was
at CAA they were my first agency Torey
Metzger was my agent Gaad her right
before got the agent right before
Sundance began in 1994 introduced to her
through John Pearson and I was with them
until I made chasing amy we were in the
middle of making Chasing Amy and Phil
Raskin cold called me and he was a
brand-new baby agent he had been at I
see him and then a bunch of agents
couple years ago left ICM and the night
took their rolodexes with them and
started a brand new agency called
endeavour hmm so four or five of these
dudes started a brand new agency and
phil was on the desk when he left with
them and so bam use an agent and he just
called news like you happy with your
representation and I was like um you
know like I mean I guess why and he was
like we could do this we could do this
we could do this
they offered to come to New Jersey where
we were making chasing amy and like met
with us while we were making the movie
and stuff we had a lunch with them every
partner of endeavor came Wow
they had like right at that point the
only director they had was Daisy von
schiller Meyer who directed party girl
hmm
so they were trying to build the roster
they literally just built their business
you know I [ __ ] like we're going over
here we're crossing the street and
[ __ ] you know there was I think a bit
of a legal back and forth with ICM and
then whether or not they were allowed to
steal the rolodex gotcha
whether it was stealing the rolodex is
that belong to ICM or their clients so
forth and so on
so they were building their agency all
of them came and I was like and they
were all like you know promise take
brought was like we'll make you money
while you sleep so like is why you're
sleeping we're working on making you
money and I was young and dumb enough to
be like oh my god someone will be
touching you while you sleep but still
you'll be making money yeah I didn't
realize so we joined endeavor and Phil
was my agent those other guys I met were
partners at the agency and the hook is
always like the whole agency is yours
mm-hmm but Phil was my guy Phil is now a
partner no because he's been there so
long and he joined up early on and stuff
like that and Phil uh you know like when
I stopped making movies when he started
with me I was just making movies and
that's all I did but secretly along the
way I was like oh now writing comic
books now I'm doing this now I'm doing
this like I'm guessing like this you
know I built like [ __ ] talking for a
living on stage without Phil I mean he
would always be like cows you know cuz I
had a separate agent for touring
colleges and he'd be like how's your
other little agent to and how are your
other little gigs doing and stuff like
that and then one day endeavor well they
became William Morris Endeavor right
took all of my touring business like we
wanted here you know that little side
hustle you have you know now that it
became that they they I guess what he
realized over time was like well he's
concentrating less on [ __ ] movie
making and he's making this money over
here without us mmm so [ __ ] and to be
fair dog signing up with WME as an
agency for touring has been beautiful we
got to do the J and saw Bob reboot
Roadshow tour because we've got this
agent over there
Seth Siegel who works out of Nashville
who was an absolute genius we came to
him gone like we want to do this and
he's like nobody's done that before I
was like we did it once before but we
did it very small we just want to keep
doing it and if places aren't giving us
offers we want a four wallet and [ __ ]
like let's we built it into what it is
man like a legit [ __ ] hardcore tour
65 cities like some rock star announced
like a couple weeks ago I'm doing 30
city tour I look [ __ ] [ __ ] 65 guy
Thursday's that came from Seth Siegel
the genius of Seth Siegel but that was
an agent given to me by Phil as my
agency grew and they became a monolith
will WMA is now bigger than CA yeah
super super better more clients you know
and there ain't no Jerry McGuire's in
this world so he got you know involved
with people like Tina Fey is one of his
clients she [ __ ] actually does [ __ ]
in the movie world on a regular basis
and blah blah blah so slowly I started
to get other agents right you know it's
kind of like also the deep now the
agency business is like the older you
get as a human being the more doctors
you get for every part of your body so
here's your heart guy here's your head
nose guy gallbladder guy here's your
[ __ ] legs guys whatever [ __ ] same
thing now in the agency world they're
trying to get every [ __ ] penny
possible and stuff so it ain't just like
I got my agent no this was one they give
him a team but there's a complete [ __ ]
team and they're all wonderful but they
all stem from my agent being like I
can't do any of these things so here
take this guy here take this girl here
take this person so there's Seth
seagulls my touring like promotional
stuff is Britney
Jordan boy Jordan not to be confused
with girl Jordan knew Jason's married to
is my like TV streaming agent he's
wonderful they're all great fantastic
[ __ ] team there's Brian effect as the
international touring guy as well but
then I met a new dude who is movies
which is essentially my agent like Phil
kind of not washing his hands at me I'm
still part of endeavor and he's still
like the guy but you know any his focus
is elsewhere
yeah and and the idea is like this guys
young and hungry and stuff like no no no
I say so and madam he's wonderful but
that's the world we live in now where
you know you've got a different agent
for everything and stuff and now this
new agent we sat around the other day
this is the original thought that I'm
trying to get back to right I'm going
like what do you what do you want and
you know I was like well I you know and
I brought up like the deposit brother
sign I was like ah he's like that
[ __ ] deal and stuff mm-hmm
and I always wonder why I don't have
that he goes did you ever go in there
and like meet with film people I was
like no I pitched things at Netflix so
they know like I [ __ ] exist now but
on this business 25 years I mean I
didn't make clerks and he's like yeah
but like that's not your way they were a
you gotta ask today he's like and they
just that's not the way they work it's
like the biggest names that have [ __ ]
shows go in there pitch those shows
there's not a single executive I know of
cold calls somebody else going like I'm
wanting this
give me your client like it doesn't work
like that yeah you got it go in and tell
them what you're looking for and it's a
yes-or-no thing it's a now that's an old
model of show business that I think we
were sold in movies and TV shows were
like if you're quiet you're quality
speaks for itself
right and they hey I like what that
Kevin Smith kid does get give me that
Kevin Smith kid I got an idea for him
when you're hot you're hot when you're
not you're not yes for all these years I
just assumed that like well I guess I'm
not hot I just do the things that I
wanted to write but the the kid that I
met with for the agent was just like no
that's not it's not the game he's like
you go in there and you say I want to do
exactly what the Duplass brothers are
doing he's gone there's a 50/50 chance
they'll be like oh all right
like really and he's like yeah they're
never gonna think to like come to you
let much like you know you made endgame
right yeah and that makes sense to me
but I was like oh my god I've been going
about this in a weird way so so your
points knock on the door knock on the
door man like [ __ ] you don't get
you don't ask for a nobody and I've been
weirdly sang that in a way for years
where I'm like no help is coming always
telling people to do their own but I
never ate their own art but I'm
different in as much as I couldn't I
can't do that I can't pick up the phone
call like and make phone call that Greg
does and be like hey man like kid like I
only got in Star Wars because I almost
[ __ ] died and JJ sent me an email
gone like if you live I'll put you in
Star Wars and I was like a reason to
live so you know that's how that happens
and like I guess I'm spoiled like in as
much as like you know I want them to
come to me not like I'm vain but I'm
like I just don't think I'm worth
anything so I assume if they think I'm
worth something they'll come to me and
this guy's point is like no you let him
go in and you let him know what you want
to do and then they make their [ __ ]
value judgment but until you walk in
they're not thinking about you at all
until you ask you're not in their
[ __ ] matrix I also think it's a
personality thing though - some people
are just built that way like you ever
see a good sales guy get on the phone
and make Stan Lee clothes cold calls to
people to sell insurance or [ __ ]
light bulbs or cars or whatever only an
only Leo in that movie but it that will
that very similar to the real world and
sense that those guys don't care whether
they're imposing or whether that's an
issue or if it's socially awkward or
whatever they don't even see it it's not
it's not they don't have that self
editing mechanism that holds them back
and makes them think oh I don't know and
this is this maybe I don't deserve it or
maybe I feel weird they deserve it all
the time jobs get your money yeah and I
just envy that gene that I'm sorely
lacking in but my original point taking
it back yeah [ __ ] which was again my
thanks to you and how kind you always
are to me we should probably maybe tell
people break the news about the next
thing that that I worked with you on
that we that no one knows about gem we
are real loud I don't know you're the
guy how do I know if we can or not I did
well there's I saw you in D on social
media so I
zooom that people were talking about
people they they know you know yes yeah
here I think we could do this well I
don't want it I don't want to put us in
dire straits here I just don't nobody
and they couldn't really care about that
you'd be surprised
alright never mind will tell you when we
can tell you but haven't I just worked
on something really fun together and
when we can tell you will tell you about
yeah and oh man
or should I say he-man is it a good time
really thank God I reached out to a
master in the universe of voiceover
acting a guy who's been on Family Guy
for years and knows that well there goes
that is the hint taste you are really
that salesman enough you like the the
riddle of the Sphinx man no one's going
to be able to inscrutable be able to
decode that yeah it is fun will tell you
more when we're allowed to tell you know
you can figure it out
and but we can't figure out is who and
that's a thing that's the biggie that is
the big yeah now yeah we're just
inviting people to bombard us with
guesses of course but how can yeah I can
either say yes or no apparently hashtag
Ralph is the the business is certainly
changing in a rapid fashion as we see
right now and we've never seen this
before
no I can't ever think even like you know
people are like well we've been through
a SARS scare I'm like I don't remember
anyone [ __ ] shutting anything down
the swine flu I'm like I don't remember
anything now shutting down I don't
remember that being all across the
entire country also on stuff this is you
know this is unlike anything we've ever
experienced I told my kid who's 9 I said
so call this in because this is a story
you're going to be telling your kids
years from now unless it becomes the
norm at which punch bag I remember when
this first time yeah right it is a
strange [ __ ] to see and what a weird
we're gonna see the repercussions like
it never occurred to me like you said
that the people who live on the fringes
of a sport like never mind the sporting
community having to cancel events mm-hmm
the people whose job it is like what are
they gonna do any SPN for the next like
just run classic and [ __ ] talk about
bowling are they allowed to bowl still I
think you can still Bowl you know the
national bowling league or whatever
hasn't called it off yet not what
fuck'em NHL NBA and [ __ ] we're
rolling
yeah we're still rolling rock rolling
stones here man come watch is Fred
Flintstone style twinkle toes at their
finest learn the best of bowling that
there is to learn Canadian bowling with
little balls and smaller pins the
bowling Network it's our time we've
Canada has curling I mean there's I
think a few things they could still do
the yeah all these you know the sport
that's gonna [ __ ] because you know
it's gonna dominate now is like twitch
kids people that play video games yeah
that's in a world where people like that
already is dominant so now to go the
other day that said people streaming
video this could be the boost to that
world it's already huge obviously I was
gonna say what have much bigger well in
terms of crossing over into you know
obviously it's it's a huge audience but
it is a select audience this could cross
it over into the world of guys who just
watch sports in general who aren't
familiar with that world this could be
the thing that here like I'm gonna watch
this is a competition gamer man I got a
bet on this I mean gamblers what the
[ __ ] are they gonna do this maker people
of gambling unless they're like now I'm
gonna gamble on the virus will it get
you a will it now how's he feeling is he
on the respirator yet I don't take
tomorrow I'll put 20 bucks on tomorrow
let's write a movie right now
so virus pandemic hits all sportings off
hence all sports betting is off Vegas
gets together all the wise guys in Vegas
get together because they're starting to
take it in the shorts because all the
sports books had to close so we can't
take any action
the conclusion is virus betting I was
gonna go Fight Club but I guess yours is
more underground sports is that what
you're saying yeah that would have to be
at that point right yeah
did you see the WWE broadcast I mean
maybe not watch it but any
think of it no no so last night they did
like Friday Night Live or whatever their
thing is and Smackdown Smackdown yeah
with no audience what's how do you do
that sport with no audience really when
you realize how big a portion of the
[ __ ] whole show the audience is hell
yeah but to give them credit they put on
a show as if the audience was there
there were moments when they were
bellowing at the audience but it's very
strange their entries dear Lauren John
Cena Santa Hattie Cena John Cena was on
the show and he came out in jorts and
[ __ ]
and you imagine if that was happening on
a regular Smackdown he's [ __ ] huge
now this guy yeah you'd imagine it would
have been like Christ
you know returning to Jerusalem or
whatever the [ __ ] and instead it's just
a guy in jorts walking down a little
ramp and pointing at the camera
no empty rows behind them it was it was
surreal it was very surreal to watch the
other night Seth Meyers odd lost his
audience or the you know they kept the
audience away right and then they tried
to do or did monologue he did like the
closer look he's like look you know we
don't have an audience we don't know
when we're coming back and I don't even
know if they put it on the air if it was
just like they put it up on the YouTube
channel but they're like we wrote you
know a closer look last night so we're
gonna shoot it and he wasn't even
wearing a suit it was literally just
wearing the street clothes and stuff and
it was surreal like every time where
you'd expect to hear the audience laugh
no laughter there's a clip from the view
where they open up the show and and
Whoopi's talk in the audience and the
audience is not there but yet their
kinetic energy is still high like the
music sign like welcome to the view
because they got to do it for the home
audience like us like you know we're
talking at converse Kant more
conversational style than we ever I
literally went through the history of my
agents something that we never would
have done in a live setting you ramada
modulate based on what you're doing but
that's because we're a podcast and it's
gonna go home people listen there's
different media these cats are used to
doing a show for the people in the room
and all the people watching at home yes
and if it's not the same show like if
they were like welcome to view ma'am
liking kept everything as low
is where vanishing you break the model
you break the brain of the audience and
[ __ ] so still they started the show with
sweeping cameras and kinetic energy and
just like yeah we're here
and then thick-cut two nominees I'm
having flop sweat just hearing you tell
the story it's crazy but at the same
time are they flopping you know cuz it's
like nobody's in the room I would have
grabbed some staff and stuck him in
jairs for some I don't know some
occasional laughter and [ __ ] which is I
think what Seth had because in the
background you could hear the writer
yeah Wow but it's it's crazy man looking
at that and then have you seen like in
heavy rotation on line is the clip from
the end of Planet of the Apes you make
Planet of the Apes
we're like it just and covers the globe
slowly and you watch the lights go out
yeah it's the same thing like pandemic I
forgot like it wasn't like the apes
hunted them to extinction it's like a
virus knocks at most the world then the
very beginning look the Apes just took
off into the woods yeah and then [ __ ]
like like this one zine they got footage
of Obama going like just get with your
families and get safe like it's so well
done but now when you watch it you're
like it's prophetic [ __ ] aint funny
anyway oh my god we're living in Planet
of the Apes then there was a clip online
somewhere in the world where they got
like monkeys running around in the
marketplace like you know [ __ ]
Raiders of Lost Ark we're tourists
usually are mmm they buy food didn't
[ __ ] hand it off to the monkeys since
there are no tourists since the
marketplace is like essentially [ __ ]
barren closed all the monkeys that
normally gather there have gathered in
droves and they're having these wars
both over what love the monkey like the
streets are filled with monkey fights
like surreal [ __ ] videos man if we
all survive this particular moment in
time this might be an unbreakable world
shy of like nuclear holocaust
yeah and or unless the next virus that
comes through isn't doesn't [ __ ] around
I'm just saying I mean can't this be the
worst Oh No can it be as bad as it gets
no not as long as the people are still
eating bats and [ __ ] there's gonna be
something
know that for facts of the ordinary
contagion no that's what they're
guessing that it started in China one of
these black markets food markets where
people eat weird [ __ ] that you're not
supposed to eat and they definitely know
it was the corona virus in general is
largely carried by animals and then
occasionally it will make the jump to
our species and they think that's what
happened that someone tried to eat
something exotic like a bat or something
literally sounds like that was injected
in contagion it's a bat eating some
[ __ ] up fruit and then they like
drooling on it or whatever and then it
[ __ ] up fruit falls on the ground then
the pig ate that fruit and then they
kill the pig and they serve in a
restaurant or some such [ __ ] and that's
that was the source of yeah good times
we own a worth of you everybody you have
listens laughs no it's gonna change the
zeitgeist for sure I think it's gonna be
a major shift initially and then I'm
guessing America especially being
America will just all forget about it
and go back to life as as usual fingers
crossed man I don't think anybody's
gonna take any lessons from this what
are you gonna do at your time down
probably the same [ __ ] I don't have any
time down time on preppy I've been
prepping for this for two years a
disaster prep for our car my life is
perfectly designed to exist in this
world because I leave the house I work
from home I work from with myself and
Eddie pen sits across the table from me
and we do the daily show and it's just
all internet and and home based so I
don't have to go anywhere and see
anybody or do anything and I haven't
practically for two years he's gotta
hope for the defense don't get sick yeah
really
back to back to on my own again don't
wanna be we're doing two different songs
I know we're doing a match as wait man
we're breaking [ __ ] brains we're
forcing different hemispheres of their
brains a snap to life what what can
people expect of Hollywood babble-on
right now you're asking a lot of this
for better for worse no I here's the
thing I think a lot of people like these
shows we always
good response when we do one for the
very nature that it is different than
stage Babel which is very presentational
and recurring segments and voices and
bits and stuff they wouldn't want to
stay d a steady diet of it but they like
it it seems to mix things up I play a
much less intelligent version of the guy
I play on the homeshow version you play
a less intelligent version in the home
sugar nuthin live oh yeah and I play
much angrier drunk version on stage than
I do here in your house so oddly enough
though I'm more stoned at the Home Show
because I can't smoke weed on the stage
when we do the show and oddly enough I'm
sober doing this which is very young but
you get a second hand huh I do I am
getting a little hot boxing in a [ __ ]
room with a [ __ ] quality.we yeah so are
you stocked up we don't to worry you
went and got a bunch you did that was
the only when I read that story I was
like a [ __ ] stock up so that white
bag you were holding it looks like you
know when you go to a Mexican restaurant
if you ever had takeout from a Mexican
restaurant and you asked for you know
can we get instead of just the regular
bag of chips can you give us an extra
bag of chips maybe double triple that up
and then they hand you a giant bag full
of tortilla chips
that's what Kevin has a restaurant size
yes the restaurant size bag of joints
hotel man because when [ __ ] when society
collapses [ __ ] will know where
to find the weed don't come here
we're armed yeah I got enough and I'm
just gonna dive into knee-deep in
[ __ ] Mallrats to Twilight of
mole-rats you still highlighted them all
right yeah that's great
and clerks 3 is also coming along nicely
although I've been kind of way deeper
and alright at this point I've got some
Masters of the Universe stuff to tie up
oh you're working on masters last the
last I know idea you even involved with
mesh disease it's a it's a it's a
program then was on back in the day
we're doing weekly remembers doing and
who vaguely remember I can I'll catch
you up on it and stuff you've done voice
work the words of Greg Grunberg what do
you got for me so there's some of that
master [ __ ] to do and then which is that
good oh my god bro I mean I saw the clip
if you haven't seen this boys and girls
find the clip that Kevin put together
with some old visual footage or some
clever [ __ ] ground oh really I thought
it was you I don't know how they got the
audio but there's a video there's a
video that then Mattel internally put
together of like hi sizzle reel of like
us recording and like you know [ __ ]
people talk in and the like the us
revealing the you know at powercon and
stuff and in that they had Mark Hamill
and Lena Headey or Hedy depending on who
you talk to
now he di I always thought it was Hedy
um it's heavy Hedy Lamarr what are you
cared about you could sue her Lena who
I'm very cool like literally I don't
mean oh what a cool chick like cool
chick yeah I got taps like instantly
badass yes yeah like made me feel you
know yeah most times I don't feel
necessarily like I'm a coolest guy in
the room but I feel like I'm pretty damn
cool and then I met her and she is like
and I don't want this to sound like
[ __ ] fanboy but I'm just like she was
so cool that I felt very like oh my god
if she's the Fonz by default I must be
Richie or maybe even Potsie
in happy days in the happy days scale
I've heard she has a very powerful
presence very walks into a room and you
you get I hit that I like her authentic
like real but like literally still
sounds like Cersei whatever she's so
awesome so her mark when they recorded
you better be damn Skippy they had
cameras to do some behind-the-scenes
stuff and then they interviewed the kids
and stuff so for in that you know they
had them performing on mic so somebody
got that and I'm not saying there's a
[ __ ] scandal I don't know where they
played this thing some Mattel executive
had played this behind-the-scenes video
but then some fan grabbed the audio
and then matched it up with old
Filmation visuals visuals and it's
adorable to look at but you actually
legitimately hear some pieces of
dialogue from the show I know you hear
marks voice coming out of Skeletor it's
awesome
it's very very cool that's so funny I
thought maybe you would throw that
together but one of my men told me they
would have fired me
Wow I couldn't believe it existed I was
like this is real but the scripts like I
you know I got insanely lucky I put a
wonderful [ __ ] team together and in
Netflix as well introduced me to people
and [ __ ] like Erik Carrasco dia Tim
mark barnard wrote script as well
what a [ __ ] what a great round of
stories emotional aircrew script number
10 and it's hands down one of the best
things I read in my life it's a crazy
crazy emotional for characters that like
you just with it it's it's so spell
bunny it not only does it stick the
landing it just makes you go like Eric
should probably go back and rewrite all
the episodes but he's such a good writer
man he'd like just what he does is like
his superpower is he well he picks the
right ones to write cuz in writing ten
not only do you get to write the finale
but you get to go back and read every
other episode and pay off anything that
hasn't been paid or you can cherry-pick
oh he's so brilliant he did that all
through you know Supergirl he's so comes
from Supergirl world and stuff but he's
just so good at it this time he's gonna
be like Greg Berlanti in the future he's
so [ __ ] talented but he wrote a
script for the end of the show that made
me go like I can we need to watch it
[ __ ] now it's so so [ __ ] fantastic
and now we're in the rounds of recording
dialogue for those episodes so now I get
to hear that [ __ ] come to life as well
so the other day we had Stephen root
came in and did another round
Cringer sounds exactly as Cringer should
sound but with this incredibly heart
filled performance he has one of the
best monologues in the entire [ __ ]
show how beautiful it's so fantastic and
watching these people like I put up the
little video of Dee Bradley Baker and
Dee came in to do we needed a voice the
brewer that does the savage voice but
while he was there like Colette who's
our director and she's fantastic she's
been doing this for years man she's so
great she's so wonderful she was like
Odie we need a baby as well Queen needed
a baby in one of the episodes she's like
can you give us a baby and you can see
it on my [ __ ] I put up the video on
Twitter he flawlessly goes from like if
you close your eyes like the cooing of a
baby to this [ __ ] guttural like
straight out like what you would have
thought was a sound mixed version yeah
of like a [ __ ] orc or an ogre or some
broken it was like they went into the
jungle and got actual audio but like a
panther and a lion crossed with a hippo
and then mixed them all together
spellbind he's a superhero he is I mean
he's done so much now and he was so
[ __ ] sweet to come in and like
literally [ __ ] growl for us it was so
quality but even even like the
performance on just the growl levels our
food [ __ ] roof like watching people
come in and perform pre-summer came in
and she had to you know I don't give a
lot but she had him at one point make up
a language hmm so that was like super
fun on top but she came dressed like she
had this red jacket and she had this hat
on which I was like man she kind of
looks like it's funny she looks like a
Mountie then she turned around and
across the back of the jacket said
Canada and I was like oh my god it's
intentional and I was like why Canada
and she's like I'm from there and stuff
and I was like that's a different world
because that's where it's from but she
grew up in the Canadian like TV biz and
stuff she grew up like really
interestingly but then when she got to
Toronto she's in the business and
and like when she got to a different
world they were like you know where are
you I'm sorry like she was like in
Canada I was like well-known and I got
what in the world they were like who who
were you she's like and after the first
season of that show then that completely
just he was a breakout but another
person who's just like so incredibly
gifted man like you are in voiceover
world you do it on Family Guy where else
have you done it oh jeez a ton of stuff
bunch of games video games and
commercials and stuff and everything so
[ __ ] it's so magical to watch
somebody step up to the mic and like
[ __ ] become somebody else it's best
gig in the world because I'm like on a
movie like you know people are no one
can surprise you in live-action when
some of the guy gets on set
you've seen him you've auditioned him
three times a bunch of people of a
proscenium in other movies you know what
he's capable of delivering and he's
gonna deliver him or her performance
because that's why you hired them to get
their essence but a voice actor can be
anybody at any given moment and
surprised the hell out of you because
they're largely left to their own
devices they'll say to you you know when
you walk in a room they go this is an
idea we have but let's hear what you
have and if you're any good at it you
forgot an idea in your head and then you
deliver it and it surprises people it's
also - in terms of like if you've got to
get to a performance way easier and way
you know like think about it when you're
doing a take on a movie let's say for
lucky the take is like two minutes and
let's say like you know [ __ ] Ralph
does it take and then I'm like you know
I cut all right so let's you know what
try it like this
Ralph does again I'm like that's you
know what let's try like this like I'm
not getting the performance that I'm
looking for if we go ten takes that's
like wearing on the performer because
like not only is the performer like what
am I [ __ ] not doing that I'm that
he's looking for but then it's the
performer going like all these [ __ ]
people there's the embarrassment factor
and she'll like that
you can sit I was standing a microphone
and do a line hundred times and you know
in ten minutes yeah
that's it it's like it's not no reset
there's no check in the gate there's no
moving lights there's no touch-ups and
the ego doesn't even fly out like
nobody's ever like what are you looking
for it's just you can just get there you
could go there and stuff and when you're
recording people for the first time you
have to sometimes find the voice of the
character like not everyone's lucky
enough to be playing just a human like
some people are like like you know kevin
michael richardson
the great amazing kevin michael
richardson who is played like the joker
he's done [ __ ] Disney stuff like he's
done everything yes fantastic he was in
clerks for this cartoon way back in the
day it was a regular on Family Guy to us
he's a Family Guy guy he you know we
find and beastman was it took like a
minute not on me and like [ __ ] it took
us like an hour like it just took a
second cuz he of course like comes in
with a strong idea where he like of
course that absolutely sounds like B's
man but in this scene like beast man
isn't as much beast man he's actually
like he's Iago so let's come at it
through that and then you get that
amazing voice like giving you a [ __ ]
heartbreaking performance yeah with the
so great you can almost see it let what
its gonna [ __ ] look like oh it's
magic it's been fun for me just as like
as a guy who likes watching actors and
actresses act like being in that process
and stop watching Colette pull things
out of people and she's such a great
Direction's amazing but I worked with
her on Lego Batman Family Matters the
direct-to-video thing and I played the
wizard Shazam and that and she directed
that and working with Colette I was
equated to you remember the old school
radios we had a dial and you were trying
to tune in a station and you can hear it
you can hear the song but it's not clear
yet so you go to a little bit to the
right well that didn't work
let's go back a little bit to the left
and then you hit that sweet spot where
the static disappears and it comes
through fully or like ah and then she's
a master of turning that dial
getting you right where you need to have
lost her cokes amazing things
I don't be pulling stuff same way like
not pulling teeth at all and also like
she's in the world of voiceover so she
thinks of [ __ ] that you never [ __ ]
think about so simple like you know give
me a punch in the face
where you're like oh yeah cuz that's
gonna sound very specific to that actors
you can't just go grab like you know you
want him while they're there in front of
the mic to give you a few live a library
for the part so it's it's been wonderful
to like watch her work like holy [ __ ]
like look it like you can literally
[ __ ] get like you said just dial it
in - yeah fine tuning fine-tuned
perfection man yeah it's been a fun
process to watch so we've got only a few
more records and then all that aspect of
it is finished powerhouse the animation
folks they're the folks that did they do
so smanos on on netflix and of course
they do castlevania hmm they just
finished their first automatic and it
looks wonderful so we're in pretty good
shape but like yeah nobody gonna see
this [ __ ] for like until 2021 I remember
being a Power Con and being like we'll
see you all I'm [ __ ] 2020 and then Rob
David's helped me so how'd he go he
won't
that was like really goes like probably
2021 I'm like why I said well we just
we're almost done writing the whole
first half he's like somebody's got to
draw all this stuff does it go yeah
you're right it's the only thing is a
painstaking process to get to the final
product that's the that's the only Ben
by the way with animation we live in a
world right Matt so more so much more
streamlined than it was even for the
[ __ ] hanna-barbera folks I mean look
Trey and Matt have the best like
streamline so much so that they could
you know [ __ ] switch horses midstream
every way for it go before it goes up
that's brilliant but you know in a world
where you're trying to do something that
looks like anime like you know that has
a specific look to it yeah you don't get
to do quick turns like that
so even hanna-barbera had a warehouse
full of people working full-time on
their stuff who could deliver
at the time you know this now it's
outsourced got to go to another company
it's a whole nother team there's
international and you know elements to
it it's like what gets done here what
gets done there yeah so but when people
say oh I honestly feel they'll love it
even if you didn't love Hema and stuff
even if you were like I never watched
that show it is such a [ __ ] sword and
sorcery soap opera bro like you know I'm
not gonna say we're as good as [ __ ]
Game of Thrones but it's shoulder to
shoulder with Game of Thrones not even
show the show weird you know [ __ ]
their Game of Thrones they're wonderful
but hey you're hanging on their belt
yeah we're talking definitely hanging on
their belt like Teddy
who's our exactly as good because he was
the world's biggest fan like MOTU was
his passion is his [ __ ] he's like look
I love Star Wars a little Batman but
MOTU is my first so this stuff matters
to me and his direction was like when I
was a kid I watched every one of these
episodes and they all had stakes to me
because I honestly thought each day
Skeletor might just [ __ ] win and what
would happen and stuff he's like all I
ask is that you treat this stuff as
seriously as I thought it was when I was
growing up and so treat it like
Shakespeare he's like that's always been
my dream as I grew up like imagine if
somebody took all these great characters
and treated it seriously they weren't
just doing tumba salts and giving you
moral lessons at the end right like it's
a rich tapestry there's stories to be
told here so he wasn't just like I want
to see two fighty fighty I want to see
them clash sorts like Teddy was just
like this is where you get to go deep
into the fact that Marlena Queen Marlena
is from Earth and stuff like that like
he was deep cuts so having a guy with
his hand on the rudder or even the guy
that started the whole [ __ ] thing
like we're all in his train and stuff be
so passionate about the subject matter
like the dream come true just such a
great job man and he like elevated the
whole [ __ ] thing throughout the
process but I forget him why I brought
him up in the first place but he he he
was the one - that was just like well
2021 is probably when everyone will see
it yeah but the hardest part is the
waiting but we now yeah to share it with
everybody else like
Journal II we all know where it goes and
like we all know how the story goes and
then there are levels of satisfaction
where it's like oh my god we all love
the scripts but next is like oh my god
we'll get all love the animation and
like we've all loved the voice-over and
like it's it's come together very nicely
I've been spoiled like it'll be tough to
have another job after this like because
this was job is working for other people
who playing with their toys but it never
felt like a job it was always fun it was
always a pleasure like Rob was great
[ __ ] and has been great still is Ted
he's great and stuff Melanie's great
everyone I've worked with is great
Colette's been wonderful like it's
if hopefully they like will do a season
two because then I know we'll get to
replicate this but I never think I don't
think I'll ever be able to replicate
these exact circumstances across the
board right
like we've got somebody cheerleading the
[ __ ] show who was seriously invested
like the same way we watched Batman when
we were kids going like Robins gonna be
eaten by that [ __ ] grab like cram
that stop this like that was how he
watched he meant so when I went into it
I was like oh great I know exactly how
to do this math because I grew up
[ __ ] thinking Batman was like in
trouble yeah and then I got Batman in
trouble I got the Batman that I thought
I was getting when I was a kid other
people did that interpretation
mmm-hmm I just have to do that for this
and I really feel like we knocked it out
the park like it is I'm not saying it's
[ __ ] Shakespeare as a cartoon but
like we treated this [ __ ] as seriously
as people treat Shakespeare that's the
perfect way to do a reboot or remake or
a continuation of a story if you're
going to do that is to take the universe
that's provided to you and then
hopefully take it to another level you
know so often it's just sort of a
literal remake where they just take all
the stuff that worked from the first
thing and then just regurgitate it with
different people involved or something
but if you can elevate it and make it
something not necessarily more because
the original still has its charm and its
quality but just different and expand
upon it then that's the best kind of
experience with that and then ours is
just like it doesn't ours just sequel to
original like we just present like
the next story and you know maybe the
writings a little a little more grown-up
than it was back in the day and hey the
voices are a little different but like
this is that world that you remember
it's not like you ain't your
grandpappy's bug in the turn oh so it's
like no it's it is your grandpappy's
eternal right we're gonna tell you a
story that you're gonna sit there and
watch it with your grandpappy and be
like this [ __ ] dope man and your
grandpappy maybe like look it was dope
when I was a kid cuz I remember I went
back you know when I forget where it was
I guess when they [ __ ] digitized
superfriends and put it up on iTunes and
[ __ ] I was like oh yeah son
yes oh no it was on DVD I bought all the
box set so [ __ ] yeah I want spin those
and I'm like oh man it ain't like Batman
the Animated Series we watch that then
now forever and it always play right you
know some of that show stuff is
permanently attached to childhood oh
truly in such a way where you're like
this hopefully won't do that this this
no that's what I meant you out you you
move it to another level so it there's
another level of appreciation be awesome
if you work well Ralph is involved those
were just I got to tell you what he did
not for a while um is that all the news
that's it son there's no [ __ ] news
there's no news just us we're the news
that's it what's going on in our lives
this is we're entertainers yeah so we
got some good news we don't like unlike
an ESPN and [ __ ] we're not like they
don't play sports who the [ __ ] are we we
could just sit around and talk about
what about our lives was a swinger and
when I made clerks like we got memories
son going through a divorce I can give
you an hour and a half on that Jesus we
can do Farabee as the show therapy
Babylon it is what will be fine and
we'll give you some [ __ ] to listen to
man yeah let's do it again next week we
might as well my god if you're around
but we might as well feed this beast
like what sit around and well let's
let's wait and see this might be like
the live show or Nothing guys take a
rest
we'll see you when you're back in front
of an audience Babel off Korona stars
Pacino but yes barn
we'll be back next week cuz we got some
time on our hands holy [ __ ] you got a
bag full of weed welcome to the new
normal fall have to e bleep you what to
call it uber over next time bring a
bottle you eBay for a ride it's gonna
take a long [ __ ] time
auctions go like a week have to bid on
the ride just like I wanted to stay so
I'm outfitting you sniping you and [ __ ]
I'm still stuck here it's like you could
have walked home but there it is man
[ __ ] I can't even direct you two
tickets to buy because there's no show
go to cease mod and remember yes good
times when there used to be full of
[ __ ] dates and stuff like that
in the meantime wash your hands wash
your goddamn hands that's people say
wash your hands and we'll be back next
week man
that's Hollywood babble-on for this in
my right first I go like see this is how
[ __ ] tell whoopee fest
exactly they didn't do this they didn't
stumble over the fact that there wasn't
an audience so they are pros um jacket
on and this even though I can't thing
you're never gonna get you do I go I
can't thank you enough for coming out
but there is no show without demands of
my left give it up for mr. Ralph [ __ ]
Garmin what's forgot the name yes that
one too and of course please give your
love to my Bible brother mr. Kevin Smith
and that is Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm ruff karma
babble the [ __ ] oh good night Hollywood
wash your hands wash your [ __ ] hands
[Music]
this has been a production of Smaug Co
internet radio sir
only at SModcast calm